[Music]
this strange robot is taking its first
steps in a small research laboratory in
New Jersey here Europe's largest
engineering company Siemens AG is aiming
to revolutionize construction it is a
big challenge to construct something
that we cannot reach areas like moon the
areas like for example radioactive those
sort of areas I think is the mean was
the main aim when I was designing and I
start to think what to build does it
need to have legs does it needs to how
arms enter the spider bot an autonomous
crawling 3d printer with a hive mind
built to collaborate in groups like an
insect colony the spider bot will
require little involvement from human
operators the spider robots are
essentially a cooperative platform where
we have a swarm of different problems
right that are working together to build
the same part in this specific case we
wanted to create a little proof of
concept right so we went for a very
simple manufacturing process
imagine a parabola like this instead of
being that small and working with
plastic imagine that like five ten times
bigger maybe and being able to
manufacture we concrete those robots
could start from the foundation and then
the more they move up the more they can
climb up because of the nature of the
overall design evolution shows us the
most efficient structure that is what I
believe if you look in the spider
structure they can move like forward or
sideways any direction without any
problem he did like seven different
designs when I first come up with my
first design I got like a feedback oh
killer spiders then I start to think how
can I make it like a little bit softer a
little bit gentle to make it a little
bit funny maybe and I edit components
like eyeglasses and I put the laser
scanner like a hat these robots are not
here to replace the humans are here to
bring a different level of autonomy and
efficiency to the process and we would
probably be seeing more of these
autonomous machines around us and some
of those might be looking a little bit
different like these spiders and but the
ultimate goal is always the same to make
our life better
[Music]